hi everyone good afternoon and thank you
so much for joining us for our good
design research grand roofing session
my name is judea and i'll be your event
mc and also the moderator for today and
you're probably here today because of an
interest in the good design research
grant well you're at the right place so
apart from discovering everything you
need to know about the grant including
tips on how to put in a strong proposal
we also have our exclusive challenge
statement partners today from grad cell
foundation and busy beast asia who will
be sharing on their respective challenge
statements exclusively alright so
without further ado let me introduce our
guest speakers along with today's
program
there are many ways to apply for the
good design research grant and one of
which is to address a real world
challenge from one of our partners who
will be sharing more about their
challenges today so firstly we have miss
pig heilin who is the senior specialist
for environmental sustainability from
greg and secondly we have mr kevin allen
who still hates the sustainability
initiatives in busy beasts asia and this
will be lastly followed by miss raksha
matani who is from south foundation and
she runs the empower initiative aimed to
enrich and mobilize the elderly in
singapore
so apart from addressing all these
challenge statements that you'll be
hearing today um you can also consider
submitting a self-initiated proposal in
your application for the gdr grant as
such i will be taking you through all
these different application routes along
with some tips on putting in a strong
proposal at the later part of the
briefing session and we'll finally end
off with a time of q a to address any
pressing queries you may have so do stay
to the end
all right so let's start off by inviting
hylene from greg to share more about her
challenge statement on designing
sustainable food packaging solutions
helene covers waste related initiatives
for greb's southeast asian region and is
passionate about all issues related to
environmental resource management she
has been engaged deeply in the work
since joining an ngo in 2017 and has led
several projects driving education and
advocacy across government corporate and
community stakeholders so let's welcome
her to share more about her challenge
statements thanks hailem
uh hi everyone uh thank you to designsg
for having me here today let me share my
screen and we'll get started
i hope everyone can hear me well
so
yes a very very quick introduction about
grab so we are
southeast asia's leading super ad
operating primarily across the
deliveries mobility and financial
services segments across eight countries
in the region and
for myself a very quick background
based on what was shared
i am with the sustainability team in
prep and for myself i'm focusing on
these related issues
and that's why i'm here speaking to
you all today
so diving a little bit into the context
and challenge statement we are talking
about packaging here today and
since the kobe 19 pandemic we know that
food
grew actually almost 200 percent in
southeast asia and it's set to grow even
more
and uh we are definitely aware of the
pollution the potential pollution issues
in southeast asia that is caused by food
packaging waste that is not properly
disposed and even in singapore um
when we look at some
statistics
more than one third of domestic wage
generator is packaging so uh
packaging actually exists in a lot
almost all of the produce and products
that we use in other
on a day in and day out basis but in
this very context we are looking at food
delivery packaging and the context and
challenge statement is how might we
design sustainable and cost-effective
packaging for food delivery in singapore
or even in southeast asia
so going a little bit deeper i want to
provide you with some background or with
regards to how packaging facilitates
food delivery from fme merchant to
customer so that you can understand this
better so we have many many
different types of merchants
from fast food to restaurants to hawkers
and when we look at the type of
packaging that they use it's generally
lightweight easy to use um very
stackable
uh and
allows for quick food packing especially
during peak hours so
you can see in this example in the
picture
and after the food is being packed it
goes to the delivery person who will
collect it and sometimes um they do
batch collecting within the same
vicinity
if they deliver into the uh to the same
area especially
and after the food is collected you can
see that it is placed in these storage
bags that you might be
familiar with that you have seen around
so it is insulated and it is of a
certain size and usually the food is
transported a via tool vehicles like
motorcycles or bicycles and finally you
will reach the customers safe and sound
so some very important stakeholder and
environmental considerations along the
delivery value chain so we've identified
uh four key
stakeholders for you to consider so
number one is the merchant
they are definitely cost conscious
and sustainable alternative packaging
has has proved to be pretty expensive
and so um many of them are not really
keen to pick up take them up and also
they might not be suitable for service
asian related cuisines like curry's
soups that we like to eat
and as you can see from the previous
picture many of them have constraints
within the shops so
you know sometimes it is not optimal to
have very bulky packaging
and definitely they prioritize what the
customers want so maybe if more
customers ask for uh maybe useful
packaging more sustainable options they
would do that because ultimately they
are catering to us right and of course
definitely prioritizing smooth
operational flow especially during the
peak meal periods
so secondly when we're looking at
customers they
prefer convenience they can be cost
conscious and we have actually onboarded
and tried usable containers with
partners
that are on board on our apps but so far
unfortunately there is there has been
very low take-up rates maybe because
right now the options are limited in
terms of where the useful options are
provided and also the containers
they are primarily collapsible for the
container so this means that
it cannot store soupy food so maybe not
all merchants could take that up
might be a little bit bulkier and also
there are other operational
considerations and when they customers
take up these reusable options the
return rate is even lower
maybe due to convenience again
so thirdly on grab a little bit
of context in terms of how we operate we
actually have very little control over
how our merchants
use packaging because it's not like
where we come in so
we can nudge and we can encourage but we
cannot dictate so that is one
key consideration
and but on the other hand we might have
slightly better control via grab kitchen
or grab my operations where we have a
locations and house like
some merchants but those operations are
significantly much smaller compared to
the mainstream uh where we host like
thousands of merchants over the air
and last but definitely not least
environmental considerations in terms of
how waste is being managed across
different countries so in singapore
we incinerate most packaging waste so
that probably means that biodegradable
options are not relevant for us and in
southeast asia it's different where
most packaging waste is being landfilled
and or even they meet
into oceans so
that means probably that there has to be
different types of considerations and a
lot of current solutions even though
they claim to be biodegradable they
don't actually degrade in current
landfill conditions or marine
considerations so paired with high costs
[Music]
that means that it is not feasible for
the merchants to take up at this moment
so what we are looking at with regards
to solution parameters uh with all that
uh taken uh having to be taken into
consideration
um i just want to emphasize that the
design thinking aspect the design system
thinking aspect of this
solutioning is really the most important
to really take a step back to understand
stakeholders waste management context as
well as the delivery value chain
before we jump into designing the
product itself although yes the material
the product is important
yeah because
we know that
there are actually a lot of existing
solutions in the market out there
already so do we it's it's not necessary
for for you to
innovate and design a completely new
type of container or packaging but
rather how
maybe even existing solutions can
complement and fit into the existing
delivery value chain food delivery value
chain
or
maybe if you don't want to
provide a solution across the entire
spectrum you can focus on one aspect as
well
so if but on the other hand if there is
a packaging design solution that we want
to look at that compliments the
operational flow of things
we can look at reusable or disposable
designs weights definitely have to be
low
stackable
and variety of sizes preferred um the
common sizes that we're looking at is
about 500 700 ml to one liter and
definitely be able to hold hot soupy
items um
as i mentioned earlier somebody's asian
could be seen i'll be resistant to
breakage and in need spillage for sure
um for a disposable container option to
consider the environmental footprint um
how is it better
than current single use packaging
plastic packaging in particular um even
if you're looking at paper solutions is
it really
really more environmentally friendly for
usable container options
as well as disposal actually to focus on
how containers can fit seamlessly into
the operational flow
as mentioned because maybe a lot of
solutions really exist out there and
for cost per product this is just a
rough guide on the cost we are looking
at if
you were to consider designing
like a container solution
so to wrap things up um
even though the challenge statement says
how might we design
sustainable and
and cost-effective packaging for food
delivery in singapore or in southeast
asia really we are looking
uh more at how the packaging itself can
complement
the food delivery value chain
and consider all the stakeholders
involved that's where the
the design comes in
the whole operational flow design system
thinking design comes in
and also to quickly wrap things up
potential market business opportunity
for the solution
pilot to be held in singapore and then a
possible discover across southeast asia
and also if there is a product that we
want to produce we are looking at a huge
amount
potentially and resources that we
provided to support solution development
would be funding from design singapore
as well as mentorship support from red
and for sure we'll be working alongside
you to engage our fmp merchants for
prototype testing along the way um thank
you that's all from me looking forward
to hearing more from you later
thanks so much hylene for sharing these
insights into greg's sustainability
initiatives and intent
hope that some of the designers present
today are quite inspired by that but um
moving on uh we will now invite kevin
from busybee east asia so kevin here
spirits the sustainability initiatives
in business asia and he's really
passionate about adopting clean
technologies and advocating for green
ecosystems within preschools so he seeks
to reduce bb's carbon footprint and to
instill sustainability virtues from
children in the early years
he really believes that you know young
children can also influence their
families and eventually society for more
inclusive and sustainable singapore as a
whole so i'll leave him to share more
with you about you know what business
has in mind i'm over to you kevin thank
you hey thank you judea
hi everyone
please i'm very happy to see so many of
you here
means that a lot of people are
passionate about the environment
and
i believe that most of us here
recognize that the sustainability
journey is one that we cannot walk alone
so from government
organizations to communities to even
families we have to engage each and
every one of them in our efforts
against climate change and global
warming
so what is sustainability to me in
simple terms
is being mindful
how we behave
how we consume
and how we live
our life so that our future generations
can enjoy mother earth in the many years
to come
my son his name is jay
he just turned six and he's in his final
year of preschool
so
over these few years i actually saw
firsthand
how much preschool has taught and
influenced him
he comes back to us telling us to reuse
boxes containers
don't buy
animal products try not to use plastic
bags because it will harm the fishes
this and that
how accurate these facts are that's
besides the point
the key is each child
they are open clean canvas and we as
adults and educators we can influence
them in a correct and socially
responsible manner
we might not see drastic impact today
but i bet in 10 20 years down the road
these children are going to influence
their social sector and their future
generations in the way they have been
brought up
so at busy bees we are fortunate to be
caring for these young ones
and in a position to reach out to them
directly
and after providing children with
quality education for almost 40 years
we now have 84 centers in
asia
and 815 worldwide
this is a snapshot of how we have
evolved over the years
in asia
we have operated for many years in
singapore and malaysia and more recently
we have ventured into vietnam
so in singapore we have brands like
odyssey
brighton montessori
pet schoolhouse learning vision and
small wonder
all these different brands cater to
different segments of the market
and we also have bright path
breitbart is an inclusive preschool that
take care of children with other needs
other than educating more than 10 000
children each year in southeast asia
we also have a childhood
enrichment arm
and a teachers training college to train
the trainers
so
for us we own and operate personally or
our 84 preschools
because
we are very particular about upholding
quality and
we do not franchise to anyone
so given our position and our commitment
to our children we have to be a
responsible organization
and play our part
in global warming
and we have committed in our esg report
that we will progressively reduce our
carbon footprint by 10 each year
in addition to all the csr activities
that we have rolled out over the years
and
we reckon we recognize that this is a
bold
and ambitious target but something we
would like to do
and one of the key strategies in our
sustainability roadmap
is acquainting the young
with environment and our efforts within
the school to reduce carbon footprint
in short our two areas of focus will be
first
embracing technology and educating the
how and the wise
and second instilling sustainability
values and good practices within the
young
so
how can we do this
i think we can consider doing this
through environmental futures at
playscape in our preschools where
sustainability is continuously promoted
through probably our curriculum our
activities and facilities
and we can look at
sustainability features like renewable
energy conserving energy and water
reducing food waste recycling rain water
harvesting composting and many others
so something
we are looking for is something that is
interesting and engaging
and probably visual so that
our children right they can learn
interact and embrace all these features
so to reiterate what we are actively
looking out for
we seek partners who are excited in
designing new experiences new
experiences or educational materials
that allow our children to interact and
internalize sustainable practices
so for example
through
educating them on green technologies
that we adopt to help generate clean
energy or improve energy usage
it may be in the form of attractive
or even interactive sculptures and
installations
we are also open to exploring
online games
outdoor play activities revolving around
the team of sustainability
and if you are someone who is creative
and
you think that you have a way to better
integrate renewable
energy sources well into our existing
preschool landscape
such as solar panels
we can connect and discuss
the how and what to do
so we want and dare you to imagine so
that
through the young we can influence
families and their parents
and eventually society as a whole for a
more inclusive and sustainable singapore
i'll just leave you with a few slides
with the potential preschools under our
care that you may be
potentially influencing
okay thank you very much
thanks so much kevin for that sharing
i think at this point there's been quite
a bit of information that has been
coming through just want to remind our
participants today that if you have any
questions at all um regarding what was
being shared you know feel free to pop
them down in the q and a module below
and you'll have a section later at the
end for a question q a to address them
so right now um let's invite raksha from
south foundation to share about
designing for inclusivity amongst
seniors in singapore so raksha and her
team runs a pilot initiative called
empower to enrich and mobilize social
participation of older persons in the
neighborhoods of wampo and bunking and
these programs utilizes a cultural
centered approach actually to working
with persons with
older persons in the community to
identify and resolve some of these
common challenges experience so let's
hear more from her today thanks raksha
thanks uh so much for that introduction
um can you see my slides yes we can see
them well okay excellent
okay so uh thank you so much for giving
me the opportunity and my team this
opportunity to speak to you all and
share a little bit about sarah
foundation's work um so i'll be
introducing one of our programs um and
uh speaking a little bit more in depth
about that um
so i've been working on this program for
about two and a half years now it's an
exciting program called uh empower
empower is very long uh acronym here
that stands for enriching and mobilizing
participation of wampos elder residents
and some of you may have questions why
wampo and why mobilizing
older residents so um
let me just share a bit about south
foundation's work um we are an ngo
that's focused on working on aging
issues and we aim to improve our quality
of life for older persons and promote
longevity and success successful aging
especially in growing initiatives in the
sector
um in 2015 we were invited by the city
of all ages committee in guampo to
create an elder friendly neighborhood
and this saw the implementation of the
community for successful aging or
we refer to this as comsa
using this essential community-wide
approach so it's not just um you know
one organization
doing the work but really involving a
multitude of services to have a holistic
approach uh holistic psychosocial um in
a clinical approach as well um so
this involves
clinical services day care services home
care dementia care
care for persons older persons with
intellectual disabilities we also have
the social space or caffeine
and we do our community development work
so that last one is where
my
the empower project is situated
um so we have offices
is actually one of the more established
neighborhoods in singapore um some of
you may be familiar with it familiar
with it
and
this has and one book has a higher than
average population of older residents
somewhere between three to five thousand
and of course
so i'll focus a little bit on the
empower program right now um our program
aims has taken the culture-centered
approach that's pioneered by professor
modern data he's based in new zealand at
the moment um and what does this program
aim to do so often when we do research
projects we imagine that
participants or community members are
just um they participate in their sort
of recipients of care but um what the
culture centered approach does is that
it centers um seniors or centers
community members
at the heart of this
program and um aims to reimagine
leadership and uh understanding of what
the community issues are um primarily
this program is aimed at alleviating
social isolation um and
and getting uh older residents to uh
come together to re-imagine what um
community solutions can look like so the
campfire gatherings are a process of
them brainstorming what are the issues
um and then coming together to find
community level solutions to these
situations
[Music]
we work very closely with stakeholders
so
we do in-depth interviews not just with
senior residents but we also
have senior residents do interviews with
each other
and with their larger community and we
work with um very closely with other
stakeholders such as family service
centers
senior activity centers and
agencies as well
so um
how do we reimagine community driven
solutions and often um
this is
often often these um initiatives are
put forth by organizations and then
there's always this struggle to get um
real community buy-in but here we are
looking at
communities and community members
driving these solutions
so we build community designed to keep
workshops and collaborate with students
so
various projects have come out of this
and i wanted to do it on two of these um
one is public transport
and uh mobility of seniors are looking
at public transport and for head bridges
in the area and some of you may be
thinking well public transport is really
great in singapore but what are some of
the voices of these seniors um saying
what are their concerns and another one
is um the other issue is sustaining
community connections and alleviating
social isolation which seniors feel is
still an issue
so um
this is um
then we refer to them as community
advocates and they are active in
designing messaging as well as
identifying the issues that they think
are important
and
we just wanted to zoom in on the
overhead bridge issue so wampo is a
little bit of a map here um
takes up this area
and um
this is to io and
so it's a little bit of a cul-de-sac and
what seniors uh senior residents have
shared with us
is that um moving around in this area is
a little bit harder especially when you
have mobility issues frailty chronic
illnesses
finding transport um finding appropriate
options to access
amenities access healthcare access
friends and family members as well as
good work
is very important to them
and this kind of
independence
enabling
a senior-friendly neighborhood is
important to them so i've just
identified some of the overlappings
here
in the underpass design
and
if they've shared that um they have uh
do they do experience these difficulties
crossing
especially at block 75
so um
as a pilot program um
we do try to engage with stakeholders
such as
government agencies so here the senior
community members have
met with some government agencies to
speak to them share their concerns
and try to plan around how they can
develop or design this
more senior friendly program
and so right now they're still looking
for options
as to what
what they can do to improve um access in
the neighborhood and what they can to
improve their own
neighborhood and
other areas
um
so i just wanted to share one of the
issues on
impacting mobility and isolation so
hearing one of the voices
of the community members
here says um my neighbor has no access
to food she's difficult for her to walk
she may be able to walk but it's
teachers
and falls are of course
after a fall the impact was so there's a
sense that
that seniors are afraid of
using
amenities like
just check the time
okay i'm gonna wrap up soon
um
seniors are afraid of using immunities
like stairs that might compose
um so as a result um
they do try to stay home and keep
them safer um
real but uh one thing that this has an
impact on is social isolation and this
affects not just seniors who are living
alone but seniors who are living with
families as well
[Music]
being able to access
important sexual
services like health care
um also
feeling like they have nobody to depend
on if they are to encounter
situations
so how can we enable this and how can we
provide design solutions for this
search
a bit of our challenge
so
how how might we design for an
age-friendly environment
um
that enables older persons to eat
independent healthy engaged and
purposeful lives um even as the kobe
situation becomes endemic so we're
looking at things that can help navigate
help them navigate infrastructure
planning journeys and accessing booths
across the neighborhood
and perhaps help them to also organize
the free transport options
um
we also want to look at how technology
might be used to offer hybrid online
offline experiences for
seniors to engage
strengthen their senses
so some opportunities to collaborate and
this is sort of honing in on
um
are we looking for modifications that
might help to build a more age-friendly
environment uh to improve wayfinding
especially for older persons with
disabilities chronic illnesses mobility
issues frailty and
caregiving responsibilities
we're also looking at
modifications that might enable safe
interactions small groups of older
persons that might at the same time
minimize the risk of a nike transmission
assuming that older persons are at risk
in relation to
endemic
um
but but then also
resolve some of the issues presented
by socialization experiences of social
media
and lastly we're looking at
perhaps new or novel online offline
hybrid experiences to engage seniors in
community
and have safely increased their social
participation so um perhaps um
the design of pods in the neighborhood
or um perhaps the design of the
interactive or streamlined app
for developing
a developer seniors of varying levels of
digital literacy so
um one thing that's also i think very
important for our work is the
translation
into
mandarin as well as malay and tamil uh
because some
so
i encourage
all of you to
[Music]
let this
affect your processes and seep in and
think about it i look forward also to
sharing a little bit more
in depth
about our programs
and how we can collaborate very excited
to hear
your ideas as well so thank you so much
for your attention
thanks raksha thanks for sharing i
recognize that the some parts of the
audio might have been a little choppy
earlier so if you have any questions
feel free to reach out and we'll get to
it later
but at this point um we'll proceed to
the um almost the final section of this
booting session and this is a little bit
more operational where we will share
um
where we will share how the grant
actually works and everything that you
need to know but yeah let me just bring
you through how the brand works and how
to put in a strong proposal to gdr
so um
there are many ways to apply for the gi
grant as i've mentioned earlier so if
you are keen to design for impact and
you would like to put in an application
there are three ways that you could
apply so if you look at the screen
currently
the first way is to respond to a
challenge statement that have been
shared
earlier you know the three different
challenge statements from our partners
the second way is to put in a
self-initiated proposal and this is if
you have an existing design research
idea that you would like to explore and
it would be happy to support you for
that the final way is if you are
interested in design research but you
need a little bit of help in getting
your creative dresses flowing you know
you can respond to one of our open
challenges which are essentially
emerging design trends that drg has
spotted um to nudge you a little or
facilitate you a little in your creative
process so these are the three different
types of proposals that you could
consider putting in if you are actually
interested in design research as part of
your design practice
so moving forward i think this is
something that many of you might be
interested in you know what are
different what are the different kinds
of support you could receive to the gdr
grant so if you look at the screen
currently um
the gdr grant is disbursed through two
open calls um annually
in the beginning of the year and in the
end of the year so we have one
concurrent one running right now that
will be closing in early january next
year
in terms of the kind of supports that
you will receive um you can see on the
screen on the left these are the
different kind of funding pillars um
sorry not planning periods the support
pillars that would help in the
development of your proof of concept and
the development of your research and on
the right um the three different support
pillars um helps you expand your reach
and widen your applications so more
specifically you know regarding the seed
funding point um dsg actually sponsors
up to 80 of your costs um but this is
kept at fifty um thousand dollars for a
cent for items that's essential to to
deliver your proof of concept over a
maximum duration of 12 months we
function on a co-funding basis where we
believe that you know yourselves as
designers should have some um ownership
you know of this research process as
well so dsg we will fund 80 up to 50k
while you say that remaining 20 of the
cost
example of these portable items could
include material costs third body course
you need to engage someone
another researcher or another expert it
also includes equipment costs and
in-house manpower costs up to a certain
cap so more information can be found in
the application kit that i'll share with
you later
the next point on mentorship you'll be
paired with an experienced industry
professional who will be able to help
you refine your concept and also
strengthen your research and project
outcomes and these mentors have often
provided our past designers with both
upstream and downstream support you know
because they have a wealth of networks
you know and a wealth of knowledge to
share with you um and this could
potentially also lead to suppliers of
other project partners and also even
clients so this is
part of the support system that we'll be
providing as well um and we also dsg is
also really active you know in publicity
support so you'll be ethically featured
on our social media channels as well as
being pitched to the media which you may
have seen you know some of the articles
from our past good design research
designers that has been on straight
times or business times
so these are potential profiling
platforms you know that you could
receive
and on the right you know i think mainly
apart from the potential business
opportunities if you choose to work with
our challenge statement partners
you can also
tap into our network of resource
partners
in the second point
where we encourage cross-industry
collaboration to know people including
tech experts or material scientists and
we also have
experts for on advanced prototyping or
even artisanal craftsmen so we believe
in the horizontal impact of design and
how it's really important to seek these
cross-industry and cross-sector
collaborations to expand and deepen your
research even further so
at this point let's move on um beat our
evaluation panel for this round our
evaluation panel selects the projects to
be supported in each grand call it
consists of the permanent panel firstly
which you can see at the bottom and
these are people who select the final
projects
through the strength of your proposal
however they are assisted by a rotating
panel on the right and these are subject
experts in the fields of let's say
fashion design or communication design
who will be giving the permanent panel
their inputs on these related proposals
and projects to help them conduct a more
holistic and well-rounded evaluation so
you know with those with so many
proposals coming through each open call
we are also starting to have a sense you
know what makes a strong proposal and
what essentially is applied design
research so that's what i would like to
try and touch on in the next few slides
very simply you know two points to note
on what design what applied design
research is firstly is to explore these
areas that we have listed out
on the slide so we are interested in
practice based research that explores
one or more of the following areas so
firstly we have systems and processes
and i think um this you know design is
often not just about designing a product
or designing an object but often it's
really about the thinking behind it the
human thing the human centered thinking
behind it so this is where um
redesigning our systems and processes
comes in so handy in really making
significant shifts or addressing complex
global issues in our world today
secondly the other track that we would
like you to consider exploring is
identity and culture and these are the
softer types of projects you know where
designers may consider designing for
community engagement or social cohesion
and the last exploratory track is quite
popular these are the new technologies
and it covers both material and digital
technologies so you could be really
pushing new innovations you know with a
new way of making something or doing
something through a user-centered
approach and you can see some examples
on the right um
on top we have one of our past designers
at zoo who is looking into designing
community playgrounds of the future so
this falls under the identity and
culture track at the bottom example we
have a produced workshop addressing more
of a built environment from a more of a
built environment perspective where they
are looking into redesigning timber
construction to be more sustainable so
this falls under the system processes
and the new technologies track so for
your self-initiated proposals you can
consider to address one or more of these
tracks
secondly an important part of applied
research applied design research is that
you have to work towards a prototype and
you have to work towards testing what
you have researched on so dsg supports
your research through a period of 12
months until the proof of concept stage
and this proof of concept could take on
multiple forms including designing
frameworks for your new processes and
innovations it could also take on
digital and material prototypes um for
your models for your tools or for the
new technologies that you have developed
but essentially what's important to keep
in mind is that your proof of concept
should demonstrate big explorations into
your research um leading to new
frontiers and innovative breakthroughs
through design and it should also
demonstrate why applications how can it
also benefit
other sectors or even industries beyond
singapore so an example on the right one
of our past designers forest and will
they are looking um into
more into designing a more circular
system so this is systems and processes
to reduce single-use plastics for more
sustainable future so what they did
through their behavioral research of how
people consume and how people take away
um in hawker centers they developed a
reusable reusable prototype at the end
of gdr um to be piloted in our public
pocket centers leaving you some quick
tips on how to put in a strong proposal
i think clarity is really key because
with so many applications coming in it's
very important to be clear in what
firstly you know what your problem
statement is what exactly are you
addressing
and secondly how are you going to
achieve that so you need to summarize
your research concept and objective in a
very concise way
and following um you we would like you
to be able to state the value
proposition of your research outcomes
and this is essentially you know how has
this research area how is this research
area different from what's been already
done in out there in the industry or
even in other countries so you need to
have a certain kind of knowledge of the
the market landscape or the the what has
already been done in this area of
research
and lastly i think for all applied
research projects we do hope that you'll
be able to
define your proposed outcomes and these
prototypes should be able to help prove
your ultimate concept so
running towards my last few slides right
now um
regarding the eligibility and evaluation
criteria
you are eligible for the gdr grant if
you have been a practicing designer for
at least three years and you could be an
individual designer or you could apply
as a design firm as well the lead
applicant of the grant has to be a
singapore citizen or permanent resident
so a bulk of the evaluation will go into
the strength of the proposal and as you
can see on the slide you know it largely
goes into
what exactly you're researching on how
it how it impacts your target audience
or your end user how does this attribute
to your unique value proposition as a
designer or as a design firm and it's
only the last 20 percent you know that
we look into your track record and
lastly we are also interested in your
design ethos and this is essentially why
you do what you do so that's it um
that's all you need to know about a good
design research grant um if you have any
questions please feel free to pop into
the chat below
or write to us at um
the emails contact listed on the screen
right now so if you would like to
download the application kit you can
also scan the qr code or find out more
about
the video grant through our website on
the bottom yep so at this point um i
think we would just like to leave the
remaining time for q a as well
um and to allow people to also engage
with us through their questions so can i
invite the rest of the panelists to turn
on their cameras as we address some of
the questions that might have come in
um since we started okay let's start
with this one for kevin
um there's a question that's coming in
for for you um asking if the designers
will be able to access
the schools if their proposals were to
be selected for the gdr project
well uh in general yes
so but due to the recent kovi situation
access to our schools is pretty
controlled so uh but if is to do with
the project definitely and if there's a
need to do so we would have to
definitely facilitate the access to the
home schools
yeah so they'll be able to um
i guess
it depends on what what kind of project
we're talking about like right because
our
our call for proposal is pretty
open
uh it can range from like
infrastructures to uh even
playscapes or online games for example
if it's online games then perhaps uh if
there is a need then we go because if
not we want to avoid uh contact too much
yeah so i guess it's really dependent on
the kind of proposals that come in and
what kind of engagements you will
require from your different schools but
on your end you are open to um exploring
that
yes it is
you have to
yeah of course collaboration right um
okay i guess we will move on to another
question i think this is directed to
rupture for regarding the cell
foundation's um challenge statement so
someone has asked if you could explain
the rationale to focus on online offline
experience to improve social
participation instead of only focusing
on online solutions maybe you could
share more about that
yeah um thanks payton for that question
i think
the rationale was that we were
trying to encourage designers to design
something
with um
an audience with lower levels of digital
literacy and comfort in mind uh so
um that's why we wanted to kind of link
those experiences because they will
inevitably be a couple
older persons that may not actually be
comfortable using ads altogether uh or
not not even have smartphones so um we
wanted to perhaps have something that
they could share with others they would
um
that uses more images rather than
language uh all that translates the
language into uh you know the languages
that they are speaking
i hope that um
yeah thanks thanks for addressing that i
hope it answers your question to to the
designer who has asked
if not you can also reach out to raksha
from her contact details listed on our
gbr website um we'll move on to the next
question this is this one is directed to
greg so um
someone has asked about the packaging
solution for single use so from the
description on the resource provided
will there be opportunities and enough
resources to set up production in
singapore if it were to be supported
uh yes thank you for the question so uh
as mentioned by julia previously the
funding
by dsj is for prototyping so once that
goes through so after the prototyping
and then you will engage rf and b
merchants to
get a sense you know in terms of how the
packaging whether it works for them you
know whether there is potential for
scaling so after if
that
hits the green light which will be great
then production and scaling will likely
not be in singapore due to high costs so
uh when that happens we will work out um
yeah the
the costing and funding uh separately
with you i hope that answers the
question
i think i would like to add on a little
as well so um gdr supports like i
mentioned up to the proof of concept
stage so we do not support your
commercialization stage but you know
with this challenge statement partners
we have on board this potential this
proof of concept could potentially turn
into business opportunities with them if
they do choose to take on these
solutions or if it really works out for
them so that's where the
commercialization part comes in that's
beyond gpr
but yeah um we have a question for kevin
back back to you um someone has asked if
regarding the tolerance level of the
school children towards net towards
natural elements so for example soy or
non-pest bugs vegetation rain water
in other words is it okay to propose
something that exposes kids to these
natural elements within the school
compound um of course undersea and
supervised conditions what are your
thoughts on that
uh in my slice i say i dare you to dream
so yeah we are open to that and
i think a lot of parents are pretty open
to
their
children
playing out in the playground in the
open spaces so they actually like it so
it's about any you know how we supervise
it and keep it safe that's all
right so kevin has already given
designers a green light um dare to dream
and explore any innovative
solutions you can
imagine
how liberating you know and i mean it's
really great that we have partners like
that on board who are also design driven
um and impact driven um and we are so
privileged to be able to work with you
guys so um i think i'm just being
mindful of time as well as we are
quickly approaching the end of the
session just want to thank all the
panelists we have today for such an
engaging conversation and also remind
the
participants today if you have any
further questions you know feel free to
reach out to them directly through our
contact listed on our gtr website so
thank you so much for your interest it's
encouraging to us as well um we just
want to
um
let you know that you we are available
you know if you like to reach out to
share a bit more about your proposal or
thoughts around how you can craft it
better so you can reach out to us if you
have any further questions but at this
point and i think the briefing session
has come to an end we hope that today's
sharing has inspired you to consider
pursuing impactful design research in
your practice so a reminder that
applications are now open and will be
closing on third january next year
and you can reach out to us with any
further questions or even to share more
about the proposals you have in mind so
thank you so much everyone who have
joined us today for interest in the good
design research grant and please do
enjoy the rest of our evening
thank you
[Music]
you